if you feel you're sinking  Justin Bieber is featured on a new track  and believers are seriously freaking out  the song is called cold water and it's a  Major Lazer tune written by Diplo Benny  Blanco and ed Sheeran  Major Lazer is Diplo's electronic band  Diplo also produced Bieber's hit where  are you now with Skrillex and the song  earned JB his first Grammy I you know  that a major Justin has been teasing a  song on Twitter for days  the release date July 22nd is also  Selena Gomez's 24th birthday bieber  hasn't wished his acts a happy birthday  publicly yet but in November he dished  to et about the type of music he wants  to continue making and it seems he's  sticking to his word music could go  somewhere completely left you know and I  want to always be doing what's popular  cuz I'm a pop music artists right yeah  doesn't mean I'm gonna do what everyone  else is doing but I want to be I want to  do it relevant  always  you